vous m'entendez ok bonsoir je voudrais
remercier arthur spécialement de l'avoir
fait venir pour ce talk ce soir et vous
parler de ce que je fais au quotidien
déjà je suis un peu gêné parce que on a
à peu près le même âge et 25 ans j'ai
été diplômé à seulement 3 ans et parlait
de mode et d'entrepreneuriat ce soir
c'est
c'est un peu toute ma vie parce que la
mode j'ai grandi dedans mes parents
étaient dedans et l'entrepreneuriat je
vais vous faire un petit un petit
feedback sur ce que j'ai fait au fur et
à mesure en fait j'ai fait un bac s
ensuite je suis rentré à dauphine j'ai
fait 3e dauphine
j'ai fait de la gestion après un master
en marketing et après un master 2 en
entrepreneuriat en même temps j'ai pris
des cours pour apprendre à créer les
vêtements et en 3e année j'ai eu l'idée
de créer b wg h donc dont vous me parlez
dont vous parliez donc l'idée à la base
de vw ghd simple s'était créé un
collectif d'artistes pour mouvoir des
photographes et comment promouvoir ces
artistes c'était mettre leurs clichés
sur des t-shirts en chaque tee shirts
vendus donné des royalties à l'artiste
et faire que ces t-shirts une sorte de
moving galerie donc on a eu un succès
incroyable que j'ai encore du mal à
comprendre en étant honnête et quand on
parle de mode et entrepreneuriat quand
j'étais en master entrepreneuriat je
pense que j'étais sûrement le plus
mauvais de mon master et entreprendre
c'était pour entreprendre il faut avoir
un business model solide il faut qu'est
ce qu'on va faire 1 3 ans à 5 ans et moi
même à six mois je savais pas ce que
j'allais faire donc c'est ma vision de
l'entrepreneuriat c'est la mode et l'art
contemporain ma mère était dans l'art
mon père dans la mode
ç'a toujours été deux choses qui me
passionnait est aujourd'hui si je dois
avoir ma vie dans vingt ans mon rêve
c'est d'avoir une galerie avoir une
marque mais rien n'était prêt déterminé
donc quand on parle d'entrepreneuriat tu
les gens me disaient donc tu commences
cette société en l3 dauphine comment tu
vas faire ton master 1 comment tu vas
faire ton master de gizeh j'en ai aucune
idée je pense j'ai triché en cours à
côté je vais
développer ma société et on a commencé
d'une société sarl au capital de 10000
euros avec l'argent que j'avais mis de
côté et au fur et à mesure je faisais ça
le soir la société s'est développée pour
faire à l'année 1 cent mille euros
ensuite
cinq cent mille euros plusieurs millions
d'euros et c'était totalement rien
n'était prévu
est ce donc si je dois parler de
entrepreneuriat
je me doute qu'il faut avoir les bases
et avant les socles un business plan
rencontrer des business angel des fonds
d'amorçage des fonds d'investissement
mais pour moi la chose elle était
totalement c'était beaucoup plus bancal
j'avais juste une idée c'était j'ai une
passion pour la mode
comment la réaliser j'ai une passion
pour l'art contemporain et comment mixer
ces deux choses je me suis dit je pense
avoir une bonne idée
on va essayer avec toute l'énergie et
toute la bonne volonté de faire quelque
chose de bien en toute honnêteté je sais
pas si j'ai fait quelque chose de bien
mais j'ai fait quelque chose avec un
amour pour ce métier extraordinaire je
pense que toute ma vie je ne changerai
pas elle je ferai toujours du
prêt-à-porter
parce que c'est la chose qui me rend le
plus heureux donc aujourd'hui on a eu
cette première structure bwv h qui a et
qui marche toujours très bien et cette
structure là on a évolué d'une façon
grandissante
aujourd'hui j'ai des gens qui vont 35
ans qui travaille pour moi des choses
dont je suis pas du tout prêt parce que
greg me connaît très bien il m'a donné
beaucoup de chance et beaucoup de
soutien depuis le début et rien n'était
prêt définit donc si je dois donner des
conseils sur l'entrepreneuriat et la
mode comme on les jongles et c'est
simplement avoir sa propre vision
je pense qu'un bon créateur a une vision
et une quitte jamais son il ya des
tendances beaucoup de choses mais ma
vision a toujours été tel je suis mes
idées je suis mon instinct et j'essaye
de m'entourer des bonnes personnes pour
rendre ce business en un business modèle
assez rentable donc on a eu des wg h on
s'était la partie streetwear de
l'iceberg que j'aimais beaucoup
au fur et à mesure je voulus migrer vers
une mode un peu plus contemporaine
de plus de plus créateur donc on a lancé
une deuxième maison qui s'appelle
harmonie on vient de notre première
boutique dans le marais ya deux semaines
et à côté de ça on a ouvert une cité de
conseil ont fait de la direction
artistique pour pas mal de maison donc
pour tous et tous les gens qui m'ont
côtoyé au début je pense que personne
n'aurait misé un centime sur moi et moi
avec du recul quand je dois parler de
mon expérience je vous ai déjà comment
vous avez cru en moi tellement c'était
bancal aujourd'hui quand on fait une
collection il ya un benchmark on analyse
les concurrents ont fait des salons fait
un salon à florence un salon à milan un
salon à new york au début il y avait
rien c'était mon meilleur ami et moi une
marque super bancal mais avec toute
l'énergie du monde donc je pense que si
on doit résumer mode et entrepreneuriat
il faut simplement se dire que comme
greg en parlais tout à l'heure j'ai une
passion et cette passion elle me
quittera jamais avec toute l'énergie et
toute la bonne volonté en étant le plus
marc possibles faisant le buzz
un bon nombre de connexions tout est
réalisable d'après moi parce que quand
je suis arrivé dans le streetwear
j'admirais beaucoup de personnes je
connaissais personne mais j'ai essayé de
ma copine et avec des bonnes personnes
des personnes m'ont donné des conseils
et être un peu coopté par les gens de ce
métier et au fur et à mesure les choses
se sont faites on a fait des
collaborations avec le bon marché avec
colette avec qui tu n'es plus récemment
avec puma et le business est devenu un
business modèle assez rentable comment
avoir rendu l'entrepreneuriat et la mode
des choses assez de façon pragmatique je
pense que notre réussite
elle s'est faite parce que on a réussi à
communiquer de façon différente avoir
une identité différente une identité car
à la fois visuel graphique sur nos
vêtements
donc pour toutes les personnes qui m'ont
entouré au début c'était une chose vouée
à l'échec mais je pense que si j'avais
j'ai peu de conseil à vous donner parce
qu'on a sûrement le même âge et 25 ans
vous en avoir 21 ans
23 g suivez vos rêves fait exactement ce
que vous voulez ne penser qu avocat vos
idées c'est sûr qu'il faut pas aller
dans un mur et être au dessus puisque
aujourd'hui encore je me dis je m'occupe
que de la partie créative mais quand
joannel dont je dois avoir mon comptable
ou monde directeur financier je ne
comprends rien à la finance dans ma
société et ce qui fait que
elle aurait pu être bien plus rentable
cette société mais je la fais avec tout
l'amour que j'ai donc c'est ce que le
peu de conseils que j'ai à donner c'est
donner tout l'amour que vous ayez à une
structure une passion j'ai toujours su
que je voulais lier la mode l'art
contemporain faire de la mode plus
créatives donc j'étais dans le
streetwear avec b wg âge les gens m'ont
pris un fou pour un fou parce que je
dise maintenant avec harmonie je veux
faire de la vraie mode pour toucher des
vrais amoureux de mode est pour
l'instant le l'histoire me dis que je me
suis pas trop trompé donc entouré vous
des bonnes personnes
soyez réaliste avec des objectifs
probable fixez-vous des reporting à la
semaine et faites en sorte que votre
passion devienne votre métier moi je
sais que pour rien au monde
à la base quand j'ai commencé dauphine
je me suis dit alors ok je suis fait de
film jette chef de projet chez du rhum
après je vais monter chez dior
je vais être directeur de bio chez dior
et après je serai peut-être sidney
toledano che du rhum à 50 ans mais
c'était pas du tout ce que je voulais
faire je voulais pas être si yo d'une
boîte une grosse maison je voulais juste
faire mon histoire la raconter et si des
personnes soutiennent mon projet qui le
soutiennent en tout cas ça a été fait
avec la plus grande passion j'ai été un
je pense que pour entreprendre dans la
mode dans la période dans laquelle on
est faut travailler énormément être très
motivé à avoir une extrême confiance en
soi je sais pas si j'ai extrême
confiance en moi mais j'ai une extrême
envie de réussir et d'avancer dans ce
secteur parce que je sais que c'est le
secteur qui me passionne et pour rien au
monde en ayant fait les études que je
fais je pourrais travailler chez kpmg ou
des trucs dans le genre mais où
c'est inenvisageable je sais j'ai pris
le pari de faire de l'entrepreneuriat
pendant deux ans et pas payer
aujourd'hui on se paye plus ou moins
bien mais entreprendre sa a été être
créateur de valeur aujourd'hui je peux
dire je suis dans un territoire les gens
disent entreprendre en france c'est
impossible si j'étais pas français je
n'aurais jamais pu faire des salons à
paris
quand on a des acheteurs de tokyo qui
disent waouh c'est un designer de paris
alors que si j'étais un designer
portugais tout le monde s'en foutrait
ils viennent à paris qui viennent ils
vont s'allonger et comprennent mon
énergie je défends mon quartier j'habite
à pigalle c'est je suis j'ai c'est que
mes marques représentent exactement ce
que je suis je suis parisien je suis
fier de l'être je veux pas entreprendre
dans un autre pays et la création
française met beaucoup on travaille avec
des usines
avant-hier j'étais dans une usine à
valcanville à côté de caen les gens
pensent que j'ai des usines faut être
stupide pour aller là bas mais il ya une
façon il montre avec des unis qui ont un
savoir faire extraordinaire et la mode
française mahmoud donné beaucoup et
j'espère que dans dix ans je t'invite
est encore un tome pour dire j'avais une
société j'ai commencé de rien je
travaille de ma chambre et j'ai 500
employés je développe ma structure pour
en faire une structure que je défends et
que j'aime de tout mon coeur donc si
j'avais seulement des conseils c'est
croyant vous moi je croyais pas beaucoup
en moi et des gens ont commencé à me
dire en fête est plutôt bon pour ton âge
des fonds d'investissement sont venus
vers nous des trucs que j'imaginais
jamais mais ses juges et une confiance
en moi des bonnes personnes m'ont
soutenu et mon métier c'est ma passion
donc si je peux vous donner un conseil
si kpmg c'est votre d'ailière faut y
aller mais
si c'est pas votre délire moi je sais
que je pense que même si une grande
maison m'offre un poste de directeur
artistique
c'est ma maison ma vision mon identité
ce que je fais je leur présenterai
toujours et je le ferai avec l'amour le
plus inconditionnel pour le vêtement
parce que c'est ce que j'aime de tout
mon coeur et voilà je ne sais pas si lui